بحث عن العماله دون جدوى واقع تعيشه عده
شركات صينيه التي تواجه اسوا نقص في اليد
العامله منذ عقود في بلد لطالما عرف
بتشدده حيال استقبال المهاجرين واستقدام
العمال الاجانب الصين التي حافظت على لقب
البلد الاكثر كثافه بالسكان في العالم
طوال 60 عاما تواجه اليوم اسوا ازمه في
سوق العمل بسبب التراجع الملحوظ في معدلات
الانجاب
ويعزز هذا الاضطراب في سوق العمل الصيني
تنامي المخاوف من ارتفاع وتيره التضخم في
الدوله الصناعيه القويه التي بلغت تعدادها
السكاني مليارا
و44 مليون نسمه فالبلاد ستواجه مشكله
كبيره في ملء ما يقرب من 30 مليون وظيفه
في مجال التصنيع بحلول عام 2025
في ظل رفض اللجوء الى خيار الهجره خصوصا
وان الحكومه الصينيه لا تبذل جهودا لجذب
المهاجرين من الخارج بل وتفرض على كل
متقدم استثمار 500 الف دولار في شركه
صينيه لمده ثلاث سنوات متتاليه وفق
مراقبين سيؤثروا هذا الانخفاض على
الاقتصاد الصيني لاسباب كثيره ابرزها
ارتفاع عدد المسنين الذين سيشكلون عبئا
ماليا على الحكومه وانخفاض عدد القوه
العامله الشابه التي ستصبح مكلفه ما سيؤدي
لنقل بعض الصناعات من الصين لدول تتمتع
بوفره العماله ففي عام 2021 بلغ عدد
المواليد الجدد في الصين حوالي 480 الف
طفل وهو عدد قليل مقارنه بالمواليد التي
كانت قبل عشر سنوات حيث بلغ حوالي ثمانيه
ملايين طفل في عام 2011 ومن المتوقع ان
تنخفض معدلات الخصوبه في الصين بحلول عام
2030 بسبب اعتياد الصينيين على الاسر
الصغيره وارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات